former Vice President Joe Biden has not
responded to another claim that he
touched a woman inappropriately a woman
who used to work for a Connecticut
congressman says Biden rubbed his nose
against hers at a fundraiser nearly ten
years ago ed O'Keefe has more from a
second woman to speak up about the
likely presidential candidate heed good
morning good morning John Aimee lapis is
the former congressional staffer who
says she met Biden at a Democratic Party
fundraiser in Greenwich Connecticut in
2009 last night she described a CBS News
what she says happened towards the end
of that evening we took some pictures
and then he came over and he put his
hands around my head and pulled me in
and as she was doing that I was like
okay he's gonna kiss me and I was like
am i okay with this I don't know am i
okay with this what you know what is he
doing and then our noses touched he
rubbed noses Lapo says she's partly
speaking out in support of Lucy Flores
the former Nevada Assemblywoman who's
also accused Biden of inappropriate
behavior both women say that nothing
Biden did was sexual in nature but they
say the former vice president made them
feel uncomfortable and violated their
personal space a spokesman for Biden
didn't return requests for comment on
this new specific allegation but over
the weekend Biden said in a statement
that over his lifetime of campaigning
not once never did I believe I acted
inappropriately we have arrived at an
important time when women feel they can
and should relate their experiences and
men should pay attention and I will on
Monday House Speaker Nancy Pelosi told
reporters that the allegations should
quote not at all
disqualify Biden from the presidential
race and at a forum for other already
declared Democratic presidential
candidates here in Washington on Monday
former housing secretary who Leon Castro
and senator Amy Klobuchar told us that
it's up to Biden to determine what to do
next both said they'd never seen Biden
behave inappropriately at campaign
events they attended with him Nora all
right and thank you it's interesting to
hear the former vice president saying
that these women's stories should be
told they should be told in context
certainly the severity of which they
allege the
things but human contact happens out on
the political campaign trail and also in
life it happens I think you have to look
at the intention to behind it I think
that's why this is so hard for a lot of
people I've seen a lot of eye rolls
about this particular about both of
these incidents and I think you have to
put it in as you said context and the
intention behind it right there are very
serious issues of sexual harassment
abuse and assault we've covered them on
this on this show repeatedly we'll
continue to do so